son annonce était très attendu en la
semaine dernière après un report en août
dernier le plan de relance du
gouvernement elle pour endiguer la crise
économique a été dévoilée le 3 septembre
on en parle avec mélanie poquet bonsoir
au sein de la rédaction de tv 78 70
mesures pour ce plan et dans les
yvelines comme partout ailleurs
autant dire que l'on a suivi avec
attention les annonces de jean castex le
premier ministre oui ce plan baptisé
france relance c est 100 milliards
d'euros avec trois grands axes la
priorité pour le gouvernement c'est
l'emploi des jeunes il ya une aide de
4000 euros déjà mises en place cela
concerne aussi la formation dans les
métiers et les filières de demain dont
le numérique un domaine chère à saint
quentin en yvelines un mot de jean
michel fourgous vous rappelle que demain
la sécurité sera meilleure dans les
villes qui rend un culte au numérique la
l'éducation idem pour la santé vous
allez voir tout les pros tous les
process qui aura pour votre santé
ils dépendront du numérique donc il faut
bien entendu que demain on est des
réseaux de qualité et on est une culture
élevé autre pilier de ce plan de relance
mais l'anis le réarmement industriels et
oui là ce sont 35 milliards d'euros qui
sont consacrés aux entreprises les tpe
pme vont voir baisser leurs impôts de
production dès le 1er janvier 2021 32 %
des tpe et des pme françaises seraient
bénéficiaires
thomas godefroy scola et président de la
confédération des pme des événements et
nous explique sont intactes toutes les
aides soient en font très bien et sont
les bienvenus ce qu'il faut qu'on arrive
à faire maintenant c'est relancer les
carnets de commandes puisque être aidés
c'est bien avoir du travail c'est encore
mieux
les troisième axe mélanie c'est la
transition écologique près de 7
milliards d'euros vont être dédiés à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
avec aussi une prime rénove alors elle a
été lancée en janvier 2020 mais la
nouveauté annoncée en septembre elle
sera accessible à tous revenus modestes
intermédiaires et supérieurs au 1er
janvier 2021
quelques précisions de l'alex kyle c'est
un dispositif qui vous donne accès au
maximum une aide de 20 mille euros sur
cinq ans par logement
et la grande nouveauté de ces annonces
c'est que c'est une aide qui pourra
faire l'objet d'une bonification lorsque
les projets de travaux sont ambitieux
alors pour plus d'informations sur cette
prime le site concerné ma prime rénove
point gouv.fr un plan de relance qui
concerne grégory bien sûr d'autres
volets pour la culture notamment ce sont
deux milliards d'euros